genomic transcriptomic epigenomic
proteomics metabolomics and other comic
data or simply onyx are transforming our
understanding of molecular mechanisms
that define how living organisms
function this level of detail is very
insightful in the right hands using the
right tools due to its complexity and
volume analysis of omics data requires
special tools logic and lots of
computational power but now anyone can
be part of this great scientific
discovery of our time thanks to academic
research and it's applications in
medicine agriculture and security
there are huge volumes of public domain
datasets of all kinds of data that
anyone can learn to analyze and even if
it's not simple and straightforward you
can understand the logic doing the
analysis graphic user interface and
cloud-based architecture tools make
analysis possible without writing a
single line of code tbo
is an educational platform designed to
introduce anyone to aam --ax data
analysis and interpretation our platform
combines favored analysis and machine
learning tools hiding complexity behind
a user-friendly and intuitive interface
in addition we prepared a number of
workshop ready projects that you can
analyze in 30 minutes or less based on
real scientific publications after just
a few lessons you will understand the
logic and will be ready to start your
own discovery with so much onyx data
available your next discovery is waiting
to happen
contact us for information on workshops
designed for any level from undergrad to
professional or academic with focus on
specific comics datatypes multi-omics
integration or machine learning